now
at more than any other point in recent
history the united nations is being
challenged
if the united nations has any purpose
it is to prevent war
it is to condemn war
to stop war
that is our job here today
it is the job you were sent here to do
not just by your capitals
but by all of humanity
a lot has happened very quickly to bring
us to this unique moment
it was barely a week ago
when in the dead of night
president putin launched a full
full-scale invasion of our fellow u.n
member state
at the very moment
at the very moment the security council
was holding an urgent meeting attempting
to foster diplomacy and de-escalation
as the security council discussed peace
putin declared war
ukraine has defended itself with great
courage and vigor
as president biden said in his state of
the union address last night
president putin and i quote met a wall
of strength he never imagined
he met the ukrainian people
but the brazen and indiscriminate nature
of russia's attack has had devastating
horrific consequences for the entire
country
russia has bombed residential apartment
buildings
it has
bombs sacred burial grounds it has
shelled kindergartens and orphanages and
hospitals
russia has spurred mass hunger and
caused so many to flee their homes
the latest u.n estimate are marching
toward a million people
we thank the countries who have opened
their borders
who have opened their hearts
opened their homes to those fleeing
ukraine
and i want to echo the un refugee
agency's call to help and welcome all
those fleeing conflict without regard to
race or nationality
refugees are refugees
for those who remain
russia is destroying critical
infrastructure vital services which
provide millions of people across
ukraine with drinking water to stay
alive
gas to keep people from freezing to
death
and now it appears russia is preparing
to increase the brutality of its
campaign against ukraine
we have seen videos of russian forces
moving exceptionally lethal weaponry
into ukraine
which has no place on the battlefield
that includes cluster munitions and
vacuum bombs which are banned under the
geneva convention
we all have seen the 40-mile long lethal
convoy charging toward keith
president putin continues to escalate
putting russia's nuclear forces on high
alert threatening to invade finland and
sweden
at every step of the war
russia has portrayed the united nations
actions
go against everything this body stands
for
people across the world have already
united together in exactly the way
this general assembly must do today
protests and vigils against russia's war
and in solidarity with ukraine marked
with blue and yellow have sprung up
across the globe
these are protests for peace from
bangkok to budapest from berlin to
bonazeri's from sydney to seoul from
calgary to cape town and even in moscow
and minsk
people everywhere are standing up to
call for president putin to stop this
attack
the russian people are themselves
asking how many lives putin will
sacrifice for his cynical ambitions
and they are appalled at the answer
to the russian protesters i say thank
you
thank you for your bravery
to the russian soldiers sent to the
front lines of an unjust unnecessary war
i say your leaders are lying to you
do not commit war crimes do everything
you can to put down your weapons and
leave
ukraine the truth is that this war was
one man's choice and one man alone
president putin
it was his choice
to force hundreds of thousands of people
to stuff their lives into backpacks and
flee the country
to send newborn babies into makeshift
bomb shelters
to make children and
with cancer huddle in hospital-based
basements interrupting their treatment
essentially
sentencing them to death
those were president putin's choices
now it's time for us to make ours
the united states is choosing to stand
with the ukrainian people
we are choosing in coordination with our
allies and partners to impose severe
consequences on russia
we are choosing to hold russia
accountable
for its actions and we will soon turn to
vote on a resolution that does just that
we believe this is a simple vote
vote yes if you believe you and member
states including your own
have a right to sovereignty and
territorial integrity
vote yes
if you believe russia should be held to
account
for his actions
vote yes
if you believe in upholding the un
charter and everything this institution
stands for thank you very much